how will you judge that this has been a
success and you know ten years ago your
vision was to get a billion people on
Facebook and people thought that was so
audacious and now it's the and you did
it and now it's the world so if that's
not audacious what is it well the goal
here is to make it so that a person can
walk into a store and basically any
developing country and buy a phone and
get access to some free basic Internet
services and that's that's the primary
goal for for people around the world and
once we've made it so that this system
is working and in every country that
will be that's step one and then step
two is actually making people use it
which will be its own multi-or challenge
just because you know without the
internet is one of the best ways to
teach people about what services that
are out there and we have to we have to
figure out other things as well a
secondary goal is to make it so that
this is a profitable thing for the whole
international operator community because
I mean that's how you make this
sustainable I mean this can't be
something that is just charity for these
operators around the world this will
work if providing free basic services
actually ends up being a way for them to
get more paying customers and more
people online and then they can spend
more money to invest and build faster
networks and reach more people and the
signs that we have from the early
countries that we're in suggests that
both of those things are going to be
true and that's what I looked the most
forward to over the next 10 years if we
can make it so that free basic services
are available in 100 or more countries
and a billion or more people can get
connected then that is going to be a
huge win for all of these people who
will now have access to new information
on jobs and healthcare and education and
communication tools that they just
didn't have before you said you hoped
for more than a billion people by 2020
do you think you can get there we'll see
I think